I don't know how people in India do the
like I'm not gonna do it but like the
mom that thing but I really like it
when I think of Indian music I think
Jogja a guy singing a scale that's very
foreign to us like uh right then there'd
be like a sitar in the background like
you know this is when you get like a ton
of musicians who are just like really
naturally talented but it seemed very
like inspirational and then the rapper
came in and she was great and like it
was kind of like rock and roll
that's so cool how they can like come
together and make something that can put
Indian music out there
it's like a popular song it's like jazz
I think you can tell that it's
worshipful through the way that she is
moving that she's you know devoting this
to God like with the roughness that
there was in her voice you wouldn't
expect her to be so like flexible and
have so much control over her voice I
like listening to it I can't say I would
choose to listen to it
that chorus was like very catchy I first
heard it I thought it was some sort of
fusion with like western music that was
highly experimental but apparently this
is just what Indian music is and that's
really cool like when I think of folk
I don't think of like young yeah I would
prefer to listen to this than a lot of
the Bollywood music that I've heard so
far when you think of India do you think
of like a song like this I like the way
that like they're singing really loudly
but it's not like oppressive to your ear
I just think it it made me happy I
wouldn't compare it to like a gospel
choir but like if there was an Indian
equivalent maybe that would be it these
are way different from Bollywood songs
these feel like they have like true
emotion behind them and it's very clear
having watched these videos that they're
very talented Indian musicians out there
that are doing incredible things and
collaborating in really cool ways but
that you might just not hear about